Sweet Caroline is the best football song
I don't know if it's the best
I prefer a bit of Mamma Mia really yeah
how does that one go no that's a private
part
I'm Laura Coombs with Mary ups and
Jordan OBS and this is agree to disagree
Chloe Kelly's final celebration is the
most iconic celebration of all time yes
sir
no doubt yeah the fact that she stopped
like that one I'll never ever ever
forget that like she started celebrating
stopped and then continued so I thought
they are yeah
I think she was I think it was like a
a big blur yeah and then she ran off and
continued to you know do this with a
shirt which I thought was
Fab the story was quite nice didn't she
tell some of the girls that she was
gonna do that if she's got like oh she
did not tell me anything she said that
yeah don't caught me then maybe
Rach Daly is the best dancer in the
squad nah can't can't be up in that
foreign
I'm pretty sure she just did a few timid
moves but singing she she belts out a
song right who's the best dancer on Tick
Tock Mary you have Tick Tock yeah I need
to answer this question I mean I was
kind of hoping that you guys were gonna
automatically nominate me in that castle
but I was trying to be humble so I
actually hardly go on it
Millie's pretty good at a tick tock
dance she loves to give it a good will
it's like you Millie Beth and Rich
really yeah we love a little The
Tick-Tock
Sweet Caroline is the best football song
You Know
I don't know if it's the best
I prefer a bit of Mamma Mia
really yeah how does that one go that's
a private
people pay for that
I still put it in there
oh I just think it isn't it yeah
I was going more changing room Vibes oh
yeah our hour's gone you were going
upstairs yeah I was gone anthems have
you ever had any initiation songs at
club or and what did you sing I actually
recently signed for Villa and had to do
initiation and uh try to get out of it
about seven times by leaving dinner
really early and then I got a text in
come back come back
um I did I Want It That Way
oh yeah you're strong yeah it didn't go
down too badly at least everyone kind of
sings along to that yeah it's no hype it
you know yeah crowd participation did
everyone get behind you yeah yeah
that is great and then a bit of people
joined in the chorus so it was actually
better than I thought all right do you
remember I had to do one tonight on the
bus do you remember that I did Spice
Girls I've got a video of that Sylvia
and I'm sure I know that because there
used to be weird phases of people doing
stuff and then member people had to say
why they were so happy to be here oh
yeah I never had to do that I am sure
this video is actually on my Instagram
so here it is
yeah
I haven't seen you
oh there you are oh net action
there you go
Leo Williamson has the best taste in
music I agree or disagree I'd put her up
there yeah okay she's actually dressing
room dude don't she she's kind of the
only one we really hear
all the time I'm agree I'm looking at
you John because I always have my
headphones so I'm like is it good
you know noise cancellation on it's
definitely good so she's the dressing
room DJ yep and what kind of music does
she put on well Leah's music taste is
like everything so I think it's her just
feeling the room yeah what it can vary
from
sing-alongs to
game day if I went on the choices after
the games because then I don't wear my
headphones yeah that's always pretty
pretty top tier Yeah question is Mary
what do you listen to It's like my
favorite rapper is a guy called NF and
then I will go straight to Mamma Mia
with no
clams at all nice
you know and that just really gets me in
the mood
no yeah
that's why I'm not the dressing room DJ
I can speak a foreign language better
than the person opposite me
English
[Laughter]
I think
there's not a chance that I wouldn't be
better than Mary well I'd like to finish
I speak a bit of German Spanish oh wow
go and give us a little more friendship
it's not a test today is an exam day but
I'd like to you know I lived in Germany
didn't I so there's a few people who can
speak some languages though I'm guessing
yeah
I thought she could speak Spanish how do
you speak Spanish with Lucy the other
day sadly speak French she's so mum's oh
true yeah
oh yeah true her and Serena have a right
little chat sometimes I'm like well well
I was gonna say can has she taught
anyone any Dutch
she probably would if you asked it yes I
don't think she's got many requests
right okay
your first one should be thinking oh my
God
Georgia stanway has the best tattoos in
the squad agree or disagree I don't have
any tattoos so they're better than mine
me neither
what about you George do you off on I
have one really bad one and one good one
of them's Birds but they don't really
look like birds I actually want to get
it removed and then one of them is my
number eight wait that's meant to be a
bird yeah
oh no okay I only saw that one I was
just like what the heck but no I get it
yeah that actually looks like it needs
to it needs to go
obviously this guy is so much better
yeah yeah fresh I'd go slightly that
with Georgia because I feel like some of
them are like so Random yeah I like that
that's just really her what she does
yeah no it's subjective it is G you do
you I back all the tattoos that you get
I think the middle ground is pretty fair
isn't it Alessia Russo's backhill is one
of the greatest England goals of all
time great disagree I I'd put it up
there it's definitely in the gray it's
definitely in the agree it's just the
audacity isn't it really yeah it was
rude yeah but it makes the goalkeeper
yeah it really kind of encapsulated like
the emotion in that game that that just
sent everything just into a whole
different Stratosphere I feel like I'm
gonna Edge that up yeah I'm 100 urgent
like I I think it it's iconic yeah 100
Wembley Stadium is the best place to
play football
I was actually thinking about this the
other day like I I love playing at
Wembley but like I don't know where my
favorite place is to play ever
because Old Trafford like fall is really
really great
and the Emirates was cool I think it is
just a nice moment like when it was the
first women's game there and obviously
it was like full yeah it was incredible
and then yeah now you've looked at
what's happened over the last however
many years Wembley's just like a special
home place for the lionesses and yep
Wembley sold out is hard to be I think
yeah how much do the fans make a
difference
um was it a dream come true to play
there I mean I think the fans make a
tremendous amount of difference I think
when you just think back to covid when
all the stadiums were empty and it was
live playing training games yeah to now
sort of like the complete opposite where
we're selling out such big stadiums it's
like night and day Pharaoh Williams is
one of the best England players of all
time
she's scored a lot of goals
God knows how many caps the only reason
she's not right and there's Kelly Smith
still still in there but yeah I think
Ferris by far one of the best England
midfielders that they've ever had who
were your footballing icons growing up
probably
you're looking at like Hope Solo for
really the standout goalkeeper but I
feel like I just used to watch a lot of
men's football still do used to love
watching Joe Hart Cassius Buffon Manuel
Neuer to name a few to name a few
obviously don't know them personally but
great goalkeepers loved watching them so
yeah Steve and Gerard was like the
passion yeah the goal scorer that that
you looked at and then as time went on
like naturally
you start seeing Kelly Smith and Katie
Chapman and players like that that
you look up to yeah I was a Lampard girl
just because oh yes
Serena has had a big impact on English
football
what type of coach is she
Direct
honest
I feel like she knows what she wants
yeah she's pretty positive I reckon yeah
yeah really easy to speak to yeah and I
think it's hard to
have managers that have the blend of
like good coaching and then like real
yeah the man management yeah
um and I think she's got the blend of
both I mean everything obviously is
about the team isn't it but she will
individually pull you to if she needed
to for good or bad really but I think
that's honesty weather isn't it yeah I
think she really
tries to always have individual
conversations with people
I think that's something that she really
stands by like
she she wants everyone to I don't know
always understand I guess where what she
expects
I feel like I speak to Serena probably
more than I've ever spoke to Mandarin
at all
yeah unlike George said I feel if I
needed to speak to her I'd feel
comfortable going to her as well which
is not always the case
Laura has been a great host today
oh Laurie you've been fabulous oh thanks
he even started off well maybe maybe we
so strongly agree thank you that they're
off the chart off the table thanks maybe
I'll go into this one day what do you
think
um sure yeah yeah whatever you want to
be you can be yeah we we support you and
your dreams
we need to help
I would beat the person opposite me at a
round of golf
can you show your swing yeah
foreign
[Applause]